and when I when I lived in China for 10
months is kickboxing granted at a high
level I fought 24 times 24 times yeah
but that's a Chinese people that's like
12.
ukrainians as well I fought a lot of
Eastern Europeans they brought me over
to make their guys look good but I kept
on whooping their guys and they're like
uh hey hey long and then that's how I
got the name of the black dragon hey
long and then you had to switches like a
dragon to whatever you look like
bro shout out to China man that's kind
of fire I want to go back I miss I do
miss China I missed my time that I feel
like it got me really ready for fame and
got me really ready like just being a
regular black guy in China yeah
[Laughter]
not legit it was it was